Okay.
This morning we're going to carry on talking about Jeremy Bentham and classical
utilitarianism.
And I'm going to begin by making a few points about the measurement of utility,
um,
which we we bumped into in a glancing kind of way last time,
but we're going to dig into it a little bit and then we're gonna move from that
into talking about a utility and distribution in classical utilitarianism.
Uh,
how we should think about the measurement of utility across the whole society
and what implications Bentham's argument has for that.
That I think you'll start to see why classical utilitarianism became such an
ideologically powerful doctrine in the 18th and 19th centuries.
So just briefly to recap,
we've talked last time about
Bentham's principle being maximize the greatest happiness of the greatest
number.
The idea being that if you think of a,
in this case,
a very simple two person society,
um,
and you think of that as the status quo,
a has that much utility B has that much utility.
Anything on this side of the status quo would be an improvement for society.
The greatest happiness of the greatest number we'll have been increased.
Now that's all very abstract.
And,
and by way of trying to make it somewhat more concrete,
let's notice two features of utility measurement.
The first as a,
as I said to you last time,
as far as Bentham is concerned,
this is a doctrine of what I called objective egoism.
That people are self interested and behave self interestedly,
but that we can figure out what's,
what's likely to motivate them regardless of their own interpretation of their
actions or behavior.
We have our interpretation.
Remember Bentham says the rare case,
as with as with the physiology of the human body.
So with the anatomy and physiology of the human mind,
it's the rare case that you get it right about yourself.
Um,
and it's the objective scientific calculus that's gonna tell us what maximizes
people's utility.
But you might say,
well,
how is that actually going to work?
So the two steps here,
the first one is that he thinks all utility is quantifiable.
Went through that last time.
But the,
the,
the piece I didn't mention is that it follows from that that utility is
reduceable to a single index.
And in this case Bentham's thinking off money,
money is going to be the measure of utility in his team.
And that means that we could think of these units of utility is having a kind of
dollar value.
So you know,
anytime you think this doctrine is,
is crude or extreme,
remember my point that this is a,
this is a guy we takes every thought to the logical extreme.
But if so you get one.
Let's,
let's just for simplicity's sake,
say one standard international UTL costs a dollar and let's suppose you
experienced to standard into national utiles of pain from coming to class.
Then I could make you indifferent between coming to class and not coming to
class by paying you $2 we could get you to come to class if I paid $3 and I
would not get you to come to class if I paid a dollar.
Right?
And so that's the second point.
In the,
in the first instance we,
we say that utility is quantifiable and expressible through money.
But then related to that and as indicated,
the example I just gave you,
um,
we can work with the doctrine of revealed preference.
We can vary the price that we charge admission for the course.
So let's say we charge,
let's,
let's imagine I'm the three of you and one of your experiences to you tells the
pain from coming to class one experiences three utils of pain and one experience
is to utiles of pleasure.
There's one perverse student in the audience who actually likes coming to the
class.
Um,
so then we would find that if,
if we paid a dollar,
one of you would come,
if we increase increase such a to 52 of you would come.
And so we could vary the price to get information about your utility and we
could even influence your behavior without actually changing your preferences.
And that's a very important distinction to make.
So we could,
we could you your preference to come or not to your,
your enjoyment from coming or not coming to class wouldn't change by your
behavior would change if we,
um,
vary the price.
Okay.
So that we can influence your behavior by manipulating the incentives without
regard to what your underlying preferences are.
And we could allow them actually just stay the same.
You'd rather be at home asleep,
but if the price is high enough,
you'll come anyway.
Okay.
So that's all well and good at the level of thinking about,
uh,
one individual's behavior.
The what about thinking about society in a more general terms?
When we talk about
utilitarianism in Bentham's system,
classical utilitarianism,
we see that he operates with these numbers attached to specific actions or
policies and that we can make comparisons across individuals.
So to put this in the jargon of economists,
Bentham allows interpersonal comparisons of utility.
We can say that if,
if you take one unit of utility from one person and give it to another person,
their utility will go up and the first two person's utility is going to go down.
Okay,
so it's a it,
it's a doctrine of interpersonal comparisons of utility.
And for those of you who are mathematicians here,
it might also be worth noting that Bentham operates with cardinal scales.
These are additive things.
You can actually think about these.
It's sort of lumps are pleasure or pain experience.
Then I moved around across people and can be added and subtracted.
And so I've put up just here to sort of,
so you can think your way through this doctrine.
If you imagine a status quo,
perfectly egalitarian world in which each person has six units of utility,
you can start RCO south.
Well,
let's imagine if we could redistribute things,
what would that mean as far as Bentham's doctrine is concern,
but what I've given given in this first column as a potential departure from the
status quo is the utility monster example we talked about last time with if
turns out layer need has a vastly superior capacity to experiment,
variance pleasure than anybody else,
then we would,
we would,
we could get a huge increase in total utility
without,
um,
by taking a lot from BNC and giving it to layer need.
So,
um,
that,
that would say allow,
right?
All we could think of this change from the status quo,
we go to a more a Galitary and society.
And again,
the greatest happiness of the greatest number has increased.
We have a world here where there are eight 18,
you'd chosen their world care where there are 19 Utah.
Or think about this case.
We might think of this as a kind of scheme activation of the [inaudible]
problem.
If,
if the utility that the Arians gain from a practicing genocide and ethnic
cleansing against the Jews exceeds the utilities that the Jews lose,
there would be no reason under Bentham's doctrine not to do it.
Okay.
Now this a certain ambiguity in the phrase maximize the greatest happiness of
the greatest number,
which Bentham never finally resolves.
The ambiguity is where the,
he's saying just maximize the total.
So he had the totals bigger than 18.
Here,
the totals bigger than 18 here,
the totals bigger than 18.
Um,
so it's,
it's obviously the case that it's preferable for on Bentham scheme to the status
quo or is he perhaps saying maximize the utility of the majority,
the greatest happiness of the greatest number.
That greatest number simply meaning the majority.
But in that second interpretation,
you could still get highly any galatarian distributions being judged superior to
the status quo.
Because if you imagine going from here to here,
we've got,
um,
a majority here experiencing 12 youth shells of pleasure.
And,
uh,
here we have a majority of to experiencing 17 potentially utiles of pleasure.
So there is some ambiguity there as to just what Bentham meant,
but most of the time he is taken as having men.
Just the crude statement,
maximize the total amount of utility in this society.
And so that nuance between whether we're saying the greatest number means a
majority or just the total amount is not something that will detain us any
further.
Now
you could say,
okay,
so far so good,
but isn't all of this a little counter intuitive after all?
Um,
if you compare,
let's focus on the difference between the status quo and distribution for here.
These people might be on the verge of starvation.
Surely giving them a unit of utility is going to be much more enhancing to their
happiness.
Then giving a a unit of utility.
Anyone know what the principle behind that idea is?
Anyone want to take?
How many of you have done econ,
the econ 101 the first econ course?
Yeah.
So what?
What is,
what is the principle that would tell you?
MMM.
What is the principle that will tell you if you have no food and I gave you a
loaf of bread,
you'll utility goes up a lot more than if I have 10 10 loaves of bread and I
give you a loaf of bread.
Somebody.
Okay.
Diminishing marginal utility.
Yeah,
marginal utility.
The principle of diminishing marginal utility.
All good things,
and this is,
this is the idea,
just encapsulate it to make it a little bit more dramatic.
If you don't have a car and somebody gives you a Porsche turbo,
you'll your tellers just going to go off a huge amount,
right?
But if you already have a Porsche turbo and somebody gives you a second one,
you're going to get less new utility from the second portion then you had from
the first.
And if somebody gives you a third one,
you're going to have less utility,
less new utility from the third one that you had from the second.
It's not that you won't get any new,
but you'll get less.
And the principle of diminishing marginal utility says that this line will get
flatter and flatter and flatter toward infinity.
You'll always get more utility
from a new increment if the same good,
but it'll be less new utility then you get got from the previous increment of
that same good.
Okay.
That's the concept of diminishing marginal utility.
You're,
the new utility you get diminishes at the margin for each new Porsche is less
valuable to you than the previous portion.
Now
is that plausible?
Anyone think there's a problem with that idea?
Yeah.
Um,
they deal with like shoes.
If you're given like one shoe,
you're going to get absolutely no that utility.
But if you're given two shoes,
like a written left,
then maybe you'll get more utility.
Okay.
So shows like if we just kept giving you lights of right shoes,
there'd be that there'd be a problem.
Okay.
So I think Bentham,
what have to say would have to be pairs of shoes,
right?
I,
yeah,
I guess.
Okay.
So that's a good,
but that's a,
that's a great example to start us off on this.
Um,
what else?
Any,
any,
anything else anyone might find problematic?
Yeah,
over here.
Well,
it just seems that if we're going by diminishing marginal utility that if you
had everyone literally,
you know,
dirt poor and always starving,
you gave him just a little bit of something there happening.
It's an increase so much more because it got that much little,
but people would still be living in misery technically.
Just explain that a little bit more.
Well,
marginal utility is,
you know,
you,
if you had a little bit of something for the first time,
your happiness increases so much more because the first time,
so if people were to,
if you were to give people very little food or anything at all and he'd just,
the link gave him a little bit,
they'd get really,
really happy about it.
But by his,
by this,
that or the nozzle,
if they're already very wealthy and they got something more there wouldn't
really be happy.
So it'd be more beneficial to the utility if they only got a little bit.
So there would be very,
very happy.
Okay.
That's a very sophisticated observation.
I'm just going to put it to one side and come back to it in about 10 minutes.
When I start talking about redistribution.
Okay.
But anything else about if we still focusing on one individual,
anything else that might be problematic with this notion of diminishing marginal
utility over here?
Let's say your C,
just because you're rich doesn't mean you don't want to be more rich.
And just because you have a certain amount of money doesn't mean more money
isn't going to make you equally as happy as it did before.
Okay,
that's true.
But why is it problematic?
MMM,
so I don't know.
Well,
well,
I think you hit on something really important.
There are a lot of people who think that the principle of diminishing marginal
utility means that money is less important to people as they have more of it.
We'd say after we said the principle of diminishing marginal utility of all good
things,
right?
Money is a,
it's a way of purchasing good things.
So your,
your example might be thought to suggest that this implies the more money you
have,
the less important money is to you.
Okay?
So you're right.
But notice what that means.
Does it mean that rich people will care less about money?
It's a tricky question because the first impulse is to say yes,
they'll care less about money.
But the answer is no.
Why is the answer no?
Yeah,
exactly.
They need more money to get the same amount of happiness precisely because of
the principle of diminishing utility.
So you got it exactly right to see that money creates some problematic,
um,
examples for the principle of diminishing marginal utility.
But the thing that follows from it is that that for Donald Trump to get more
utility,
you have to give him a huge amount of new money just to,
for him to get the same amount of new utility as somebody who only has $10,000.
Right?
So the,
the way to think about the desire for money,
it's a bit like sort of a heroin addict needs more and more and more new heroin
to get the same head,
right?
So the more money you have,
actually,
the more money you will want in order to get the next marginal increment of
utility.
So we should expect rich people to be greedy by this theory,
not to become more and more indifferent to money.
Very important assumption and a lot of people get that wrong when they think
about the principle of diminishing marginal utility.
There are any other examples of this doctrine that might make it seem
problematic?
Yeah,
over there.
Second Force Turbo.
If I had a second Porsche turbo,
I would be just really reckless with it and I could do whatever I want.
Like I wouldn't have to protect the first Porsche turbo as much.
Yeah.
But I mean it's like,
I mean there's more you can do with it,
right?
Yeah.
So why is that a problem?
Well then wouldn't the second car,
I mean like say CV,
you have like,
you know you're,
you have a little bit and you're given a little bit,
your utility goes up,
but you really want to protect that little bit.
But when you get more,
maybe it encourages you to to to say money.
Spend
the second one.
What are you saying?
You wouldn't want the second one,
but why wouldn't I want that?
If you had one you will.
And I said,
I'll give you,
I'll give you my one.
It's right out there.
You wouldn't want it.
It's not the,
it's not that I wouldn't want it
say like Jay Leno who like,
right,
how many cars does Jay Leno happy?
Too Big.
It's not that it wouldn't want it,
but maybe the utility for the second one in some cases would be more than the
utility for the first one.
So the curve would be thrown away
because you want to protect that first one,
like so.
So I mean,
so you don't lose what little you have.
Okay.
So that's a possibility.
Any,
any other examples of where this becomes problematic?
I mean,
think about bear
one beer increases your utility a lot the next,
you know,
and then [inaudible] and the 14th.
And it is,
this is an economic at some,
you know,
or taking an aspirin,
isn't it kind of,
you know,
no.
Uh,
what about other values like integrity?
If you have a little bit of integrity,
uh,
and you get some more,
but if you have a lot of integrity,
you know,
like,
uh,
a little bit more,
it's still worse than equal.
The integrity is a great example because why don't you start putting values like
that out there?
It threat,
I think,
threatens the idea that it's all reducible to a single index,
right?
Because,
mmm,
you can't,
having a little bit of integrity,
sort of like being a little bit pregnant,
right.
One once Elliot speced it spits his integrity as blown.
It's not like he's there.
There's some it,
it's,
it's a binary good either habit or you doubt.
Right.
People think he's either a hypocrite or is not.
It's a binary thing.
It's maybe some people are somewhat hypocritical,
but it's,
it seems like it's a,
there's a threshold there,
one side of her or the other.
And so there might be some good just like integrity that are not easily
capturable in this logic.
We should put that out there.
But yeah,
over here.
What about like a health,
I mean it's not quite binary,
you know,
cause you can be in medium health,
but I think it would be pretty useful to be healthy and then super healthy.
Like I gets,
you know,
add Infinium Infinium
health.
The thing about health,
it's,
it's tricky to actually less so in our day then Bentham's it's tricky to think
about redistributing health,
right?
Although,
you know,
uh,
you'll see that there we,
we will come up against some pretty bizarre cases.
I,
if,
you know,
if some people are cited and some people are blind,
you could transfer and you could do eye transplants.
Should we be transplanting from the sight to the blind?
Are you Billy?
You know,
the blind person would gain more utility from getting one.
I then a sighted person would get loose from losing one eye.
So shouldn't we do that?
So that can be also give you some,
some ways of proceeding that would make you queasy,
right?
If you allow the principle of diminishing marginal utility,
what,
what would,
what about the examples I threw out there?
Bare and aspirins.
They're a bit like the sort of left shoe examples,
right?
I don't think those ashy deep problems for Bentham's theory because I think what
he would say as well,
uh,
you,
your drink beer,
at some point you would start,
you would sell the beer rather than make yourself paralytic drunk,
uh,
and feel terrible.
You'd sell the and use that to buy some other guard,
uh,
that would give you increasing utility at a diminishing marginal rate.
So,
um,
the main thing is that the fungibility of utility in it and it's,
express ability in terms of money,
although as was pointed out here,
um,
when we think about the diminishing marginal utility even have money,
we shouldn't think that that makes you care less about money.
The richer you get,
we have that.
It will make you care more about money,
the richer that you get.
Okay.
Now here's a,
here's this historical statement about the principle of diminishing marginal
utility.
Every serious economist since the 18th century has assumed that the principle of
diminishing marginal utility is true,
including Jeremy Bentham.
You can do economics without assuming that the principle of diminishing marginal
utility is true.
And I think if you throw out some of these problematic instances like integrity,
um,
I think that what,
what Bentham would have said or what any economist would have said,
well,
yes,
there are some things that are not capturable easily or easily captured by this
idea,
but it's if you want to get it right,
if you want to see how people are going to behave,
if you want to get it right,
it's a better assumption than any of the competing assumptions you could make.
It's going to get you closer to the truth more of the time.
Then not assuming the principle of diminishing marginal utility is true.
So Bentham would have probably said that I th I think if questioned or if
somebody had probed with some of these counter examples,
so it's,
it's the best assumption you can make given that you've got to assume something.
But now,
and now I want to come back to the sophisticated point that was made in the
middle at the back there a few minutes ago.
When you start to think about the utility that people at the bottom of the
social order derived from a particular good versus the utility that the people
at the top of the social order derive from some particular good.
Because in Bentham scheme,
remember we are allowing
comparisons across individuals.
Let's suppose a two person society again.
Um,
and let's suppose it consists of Donald Trump.
It can be a multiperson society,
but we just to focus to Donald Trump and a homeless woman living out of a,
out of a left luggage locker in grand central station.
Actually they know lockers at grand central,
but there are at Penn at Penn station.
Okay.
MMM.
And the question is,
should we take a dollar from Trump and give it to the bag lady?
What,
what should we,
yes.
No.
How many think yes?
Okay.
Yeah.
Almost everybody.
Why?
Because by assumption with the principle of diminishing marginal utility,
we take the dollar off on Trump up there.
He,
his loss of utilities negligible,
but we give it to the,
the woman,
uh,
who is starving down here and her gain.
And you tell these enormous from that dollar,
right?
So we should take the dollar from Trump.
Let's assume there's no dead weight loss to the government and all of that for
right now,
we will just keep it simple.
We should take that dollar from Trump and we should give it to the bag lady and
the greatest happiness of the greatest number.
Well,
having creased,
right?
But then maybe we should take another dollar,
shouldn't we?
I mean it worked the first time.
So we should take a second dollar from Trump and give it to the bag lady and the
third dollar and a fourth dollar.
When are we going to stop?
Yup.
Yeah.
We're going to stop at the point of perfect equality,
right?
We're going to keep redistributing until they have the same amount.
So now you should be able to start to see why classical.
You'll tell a terrorism was a doctrine that was thought to be profoundly radical
and frightening to rich man because it has this built in impetus for downward
redistribution.
You can say,
well,
they'll be cost,
they'll be dead weight loss.
To the state and so on,
but still the underlying logic says,
take it from Trump and give it to the bag lady right at the margin.
That's what you should do,
and bent them completely sore that this was an implication of his doctrine.
Now,
Bentham was a fairly radical guy.
He was a supporter of democracy,
which was a radical thing at that time,
but he wasn't he.
He washed on this egalitarian as all of that and he wanted to temper
the downward redistribution that flows from his principal and so
he makes a distinction.
Okay.
Between what he refers to as absolute and practical equality.
He says,
suppose by the commencement be made by the power of a government of any kind in
the design of establishing it,
absolute equality that's redistributing to equality.
The effect would be that instead of everyone's having an equal share in the some
of the objects of general desire and in particular the means of subsistence and
the matter of abundance,
no one would have any share of it at all before any division of it could be
made.
The hole would be destroyed and destroyed along with it,
by those,
those by whom as well as those for the sake of whom did the division had been
ordained.
He's basically saying if you want to reduce that to a bumper sticker is saying
the rich will burn that crops before giving them to the poor.
And that is a common argument in politics.
It's the sort of reverse of trickle down,
right?
Trickled down is the notion that you allow inequality because the rich create
more wealth for everybody,
right?
The pie bigger for everybody.
And so the greatest amount of utility is increased by allowing inequality.
This is the inverse claim.
Bentham's saying,
well,
yes,
in principle absolute equality would maximize the greatest happiness of the
greatest number.
But in fact,
if a government set out to do that,
the rich would rebel.
And this is a claim that is often made in every day politics.
So,
um,
you'll destroy incentives to work is the claim that you'll hear a,
when we have arguments about raising taxes in the run up to the fall elections,
right
in the transition to democracy in South Africa,
people said the wipe pharmas will destroy their farms before turning them over
to the majority turned out not to be true.
So Tho those examples put on the table,
what sort of forest is this claim have?
It's really an empirical claim
and we don't really know how much the rich will before burning their crops be
zoom.
I believe they'll allow some redistributive taxation,
but we don't know how much and a lot of the day to day argument of politics
turns around how much.
So Bentham makes a distinction between absolute and practical equality and he
says we should redistribute to the point of practical equality,
but not to the point of absolute equality because it has redistributing beyond
practical equality has this perverse counter trickle down logic and that's not
going to be acceptable.
Okay.
From the standpoint of the principle of utility.
So when you allow both interpersonal comparisons of utility in you assume
diminishing marginal utility,
utilitarianism becomes a very radical doctrine.
You can hedge it in to some extent with claims of this sort.
Okay.
But they are themselves controversial and you're going to get into a very messy
world of macroeconomic predictions and counter predictions about whether and
when you reach this point of practical equality,
uh,
when the,
the,
uh,
gains from downward redistribution offset by the losses from the shrinking of
the pie.
Now some of you might've said,
well,
at the beginning of this course of lectures,
Shapiro said every enlightenment thinker is committed to too.
Okay?
Postulates.
One is that we can have a scientific theory of politics.
And the other is that individual freedom operationalized as a doctrine of rights
is the most important.
Good.
Now,
having sat through these lectures on Benson,
I can see what he's saying about science.
You know,
Bentham has this monomaniacal view of science.
He's got his objective egoism.
He can figure it all out.
What,
what will maximize social utility and run around the world?
Writing Constitutions for people can devise a whole public policy that's going
to scientifically maximize the utility of society,
but you know,
I'm not seeing a whole lot of room for rights in this doctorate.
It seems to allow ethnic cleansing,
even genocide.
It seems to allow redistribution from one person to another all justified on the
grounds that this is maximizing total utility of society.
Well even if it is,
how does this respect individual rights?
My just wrong.
If there's something,
some elementary thing I've missed here,
there's not much room for rights in Bentham's doctrine.
Well,
I'm just wrong that these enlightenment thinkers,
we're committed to individual rights.
It would be a reasonable inference from what I've said so far,
but remember
well Bentham,
when we try to maximize you tell it in the society.
Individual motivation is vital.
This is a passage I I read to you last week,
but I'm just repeating it.
The greatest enemies of public is ah,
the selfish and this social passions necessary as they are.
Society is held together only by the sacrifices that men can be induced to make
of the gratifications.
They demand to obtain these sacrifices.
Is the greatest difficulty,
the greatest task of government.
He's saying you have to work with individual motivations.
You can't ignore them.
And I think that's,
that is the point that's behind his distinction between absolute and practical
equality.
The ritual burn the crops before giving them to the poor.
You have to take that into account.
You have to see individuals as the basic generators of utility.
In another piece of phantoms writing,
which I didn't have your read,
but I'll just put it out there because it's,
it's where you start to see our old friend,
the workmanship ideal,
creeping by the back door into utilitarianism.
Bentham says,
Lord does not say to man work and I will reward you,
but it says Labor.
And by stopping the hand that would take them from you,
I will ensure you the fruits of your labor.
It's natural,
insufficient reward without which w without me,
you cannot preserve.
If industry creates,
it is law,
which preserves if at the first we owe everything to labor at the second and
every succeeding moment,
we are everything to law.
So another way of thinking about this is that Ben femmes idea of the state is
essentially regulatory.
It stays the hand of the somebody else who would steal your goods,
but the cannot itself create utility.
Labor creates utility.
And this is why I say that workmanship are all I,
that idea that we first confronted when we talked about lock comes into
utilitarianism by the back door because Ben time's going to say,
unless you respect individual rights,
you're not going to be a ball to maximize utility for the society as a whole.
So the state is basically a regulative state,
not a state that's actively involved in creating utility for individuals.
A,
we'll do some redistribution to the point of practical equality.
But the basic idea is that the state should be hands off with respect to the
utility creation in the society.
It's industry that creates utility labor work.
So incentives are going to be important going forward if you're going to
maximize utility.
So that's the way in which we see that even a classical utilitarian like Bentham
is gonna resist.
Yeah.
Dispensing with the doctrine of individual rights.
Now there's a problem with his mode of doing this and the problem arises because
the claim that the rich will burn that crops before giving them to the poor
might not be true.
Yeah.
And even if we get to last extreme circumstances like South Africa before and
after the transition,
when we look at actual debates in contemporary politics in the United States,
this is what we see.
Ronald Reagan comes in and says,
if we cut taxes,
this is a 1980 if we cut taxes,
um,
the pie will get bigger for all and there'll be actually more revenue.
And so utilitarianism says,
do it.
And the Democrats say no,
now they wowed.
Um,
and it's an empirical argument and you will fine.
I,
if you go back now and look at what happened during the 1980s perfectly credible
economists will line up on both sides because they cut the taxes bought,
of course,
eight other things happen as well that affect the macro economy.
Right?
And disentangling who got who,
how much the tax cuts were responsible for happened versus how much many other
things that happened were responsible.
Nobody really knows.
Or if you look at the current debate we've watched and are watching unfold about
the economic stimulus.
If the economy turns around between now and November,
you know,
the Democrats will probably do a lot better than if it doesn't.
Um,
but you know,
the Republicans will say,
well,
it would have turned around faster if we hadn't had all this taxation,
you know,
and Paul Krugman will say,
well,
it would have turned around even faster if we'd had more taxation.
And so a lot of the problem in debating incentives once you get into the real
world of macro economic policy making is that a,
you never have the counterfactual.
You can't go and rerun history without the stimulus.
Right.
Well,
without the Reagan tax cuts and be the sheer complexity.
So many other things happen.
The price of oil goes up or the,
you know,
commodities collapse or the dollar or this or that or the Chinese,
revalued,
do or don't change the value of that currency so that when it gets down to it,
when it gets down to it,
you're not going to get a definitive answer to the question.
What is the point of practical equality?
When are we past the point of practical equality?
Okay.
To use Bentham's terminology,
oh,
we close to it and we gone by it or we know where near it.
You know there've been periods in our history when we've had marginal top
marginal tax rates of 90%
right?
Reagan thought a top marginal tax rate of 40% was beyond the point of practical
equality.
You never going to get a definitive resolution of those questions,
but if we think back to what the aspiration of the early enlightenment was,
it was certainty
to use.
The example,
remember I read you from Hobbs is six professors of his epistle dedicated re on
the to the six professors of mathematics.
He said for the things we don't make,
we can't know.
We can only guess about the causes,
right?
Well here we are guessing about the causes.
We don't really know and there will be the people who want either policy will be
able to find a plausible,
a set of experts to defend their view.
So you get into this very messy world of macro economic prediction.
If you want to put some limits on the radical edge of classical utilitarianism
[inaudible] as a matter of history,
that's not how it went.
As a matter of history.
How it went
was to rethink the analytical structure of utilitarianism in a way that
completely defanged it's radical redistributive edge without any reference to
these messy macro economic considerations and just how that happened in the
transition from classical to what we're going to call neoclassical
utilitarianism is the subject with which I will begin on Wednesday.
See you then.